aber über und wird nicht jede woche
gelacht da sind wir nicht obwohl auch
bei uns in der redaktion
[Musik]
der kampf hat sich gelohnt
werner winkler ich bin heute hier um
sein vieh zu feiern und zwar so dass
selbst das obama lager noch was lernen
kann
die grünen mitglieder haben entschieden
und sie haben katrin göring eckardt und
jürgen trittin zum spitzenduo für die
bundestagswahl 2013 gewählt war
[Musik]
das schon offensichtlich wahlbetrug was
hier passiert ist oder der name mit dem
alle gerechnet haben ist nicht dabei für
kandidat werner ja natürlich
wie viel von der zum greifen 1000er im
kommerner winkler 4 660 sie war nicht
alleine
dieser weg ist und trittin vier weitere
jahre bundestagsmandat sicherheit muss
ich natürlich auch gucken wo ich bleibe
nach
viele
ums leben
[Musik]
schön dass sie sich jetzt die seite des
erfolges sein wissen ist unser gesamtes
ist schon bitter für die heute show das
will hier kandidat nicht zum erfolg
geheißen sie alle anstrengungen zum
trotz wir haben hier eine daten- und
egal was die basis gesagt dass ich immer
an sie geglaubt wenn man sich die
aktuellen umfragen zur urabstimmung so
anschaut dann fragt man sich natürlich
warum hasst die basis die so immer wenn
an vielen dank werner winkler und alles
gute weiterhin wieder kandidatin lena
gesagt wenn das pferd reitest du von
absteigen jetzt wollten wir von der
heutige ein abknicken
wer hätte gedacht dass gibt es da noch
einen drauf heute also aber über uns
wird nicht jede woche gelacht nutzen
oder lieber jochen ich bin ehrlich
wenn sie allerdings noch mal anrufen
während der graf ich nie wieder bei mir
melden spitze in deutschland
danke schön viel glück die besten super
super die beiden hab immer gesagt sorry
werner aber es muss auch gucken wo ich
bleiben es aber grund doch einfach seine
eigene partei bündnis 12 die winklers
viel erfolg damit gehabt machte recht
noch eine anzahl heim
wie wirst du immer so lustig